digamos que tenemos un examen
estandarizado donde cada pregunta del
examen tiene cuatro posibles opciones de
respuesta la opción a la opción b la
opción c y la opción de las personas que
diseñaron el examen aseguran que al paso
de muchos años las opciones a b c yd
tiene la misma probabilidad de ser la
respuesta correcta para cualquiera de
las preguntas es decir que la respuesta
correcta tiene una probabilidad del 25
por ciento de estar en cualquiera de las
opciones ahora digamos que ustedes
tienen una corazonada de que las
respuestas tienen una desviación hacia
una opción u otra como podemos probar
esto podemos comenzar con una hipótesis
nula y con una hipótesis alternativa de
manera que podamos hacer una prueba de
hipótesis digamos que la hipótesis nula
es las opciones correctas se distribuyen
de igual manera es decir que hacer ya la
opción correcta el 25% de las veces de
el 25% de las veces se el 25% de las
veces y de el 25% de las veces la
hipótesis alternativa es que las
opciones correctas no se distribuyen de
igual
era como vamos a probar las hipótesis ya
sabemos cómo comenzar con estas pruebas
primero tenemos la población de todos
los elementos posibles y tomamos una
muestra digamos que la muestra es de 100
elementos por lo que n es igual a 100
vamos a escribir los datos que obtenemos
de esa muestra esta es la opción
correcta este sería el número esperado y
este es el número real en un momento
veremos a qué nos referimos con esto
tenemos cuatro opciones diferentes a b c
y d
recordemos que en una prueba de
hipótesis empezamos por suponer que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera en este caso
la hipótesis nula es la que dice que
todas las opciones tienen la misma
probabilidad de ser la opción correcta
así que el número esperado de la opción
a sería el 25% de estos 100 elementos
que es 25 lo mismo pasa para la opción b
para la opción c y la opción de ahora
digamos que los resultados reales que
encontramos para cada opción al analizar
los 100 elementos son la opción a fue la
opción correcta 20 veces la opción b fue
la correcta 20 veces
la opción se fue la opción correcta 25
veces y la opción de fue la correcta 35
veces al ver las cantidades reales
podríamos pensar que d tiene una
frecuencia más alta pero recordemos que
esto es solamente una muestra y por
aleatoriedad obtuvimos más opciones de
que las otras hay cierta probabilidad de
obtener este resultado aún suponiendo
que la hipótesis nula es verdadera esta
es justamente la meta de estas pruebas
de hipótesis saber cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener un resultado por
lo menos así de extremo y si esa
probabilidad es menor que cierto umbral
entonces tendemos a rechazar la
hipótesis nula y aceptar la alternativa
estos umbrales los hemos visto con
anterioridad como niveles de
significancia digamos que el nivel de
significancia es del 5% por lo que si la
probabilidad de obtener este resultado o
algún resultado más alejado de lo
esperado es menor que este umbral
entonces rechazamos la hipótesis nula
todo esto nos lleva a una cuestión
interesante cómo podemos calcular la
probable
de tener un resultado así de extremo o
más extremo como podemos medirlo pues
vamos a ver un estadístico nuevo para
ayudarnos con esta cuestión así como
también veremos una nueva letra griega
la letra g mayúscula que parece como una
equis pero algo más curvada el
estadístico se llama ji cuadrada y es
una forma de calcular la diferencia
entre el valor real y el valor esperado
y traducir esto en un número la
distribución de ji cuadrada está muy
bien estudiada y la podemos usar para
encontrar la probabilidad de obtener un
resultado así de extremo o más extremo
si el número obtenido es menor que el
nivel de significancia entonces
rechazamos la hipótesis nula lo cual
sugiere la alternativa como calculamos
el estadístico he cuadrada no es difícil
para cada una de estas categorías
calculamos la diferencia entre el valor
real y el valor esperado para la opción
a el valor real es 20 y le restamos el
valor esperado de 25 elevamos al
cuadrado esta diferencia y la dividimos
entre el valor esperado le sumamos lo
mismo para la
opción b 20 menos 25 al cuadrado entre
25 que es el valor esperado sumamos para
la opción c 25 menos 25 al cuadrado
entre 25 y por último sumamos para la
opción de 35 menos 25 al cuadrado entre
25 si calculamos esto tenemos 20 menos
25 al cuadrado nos da 25 esto también da
25 esto es 0 35 menos 25 es 10 al
cuadrado es 100 tenemos uno más uno más
04 por lo que el estadístico cuadrada en
este ejemplo es igual a 6 y ahora qué
hacemos con este número pues lo podemos
buscar en la distribución y cuadrada
para los grados de libertad apropiados
de los cuales hablaremos en un momento y
encontrar cuál es la probabilidad de que
el estadístico cuadrada sea igual o
mayor que 6 para entender cómo se ve una
distribución cuadrada aquí vemos varias
distribuciones y para diferentes grados
de libertad
para calcular los grados de libertad
tenemos que ver el número de categorías
que tenemos en nuestro ejemplo tenemos
cuatro categorías y vamos a restarle uno
a este número esto tiene mucho sentido
porque si supiéramos con anticipación
cuántos valores de a dv
dice o de de ay si supiéramos las
proporciones e incluso las proporciones
supuestas entonces siempre podemos
calcular la cuarta es por eso que
tenemos cuatro menos 1 grados de
libertad son 3 en la gráfica los grados
de libertad pueden estar representados
con una capa la línea de acá igual a 3
es de color azul claro así que nos vamos
a fijar en esta línea azul que
corresponde a 3 grados de libertad y
queremos encontrar la probabilidad de
obtener un estadístico he cuadrada que
sea mayor o igual que 6 así que nos
interesa esta área de acá podemos
encontrar esto usando una calculadora o
si estamos resolviendo un examen tipo ap
statistics podemos usar las tablas que
nos proporcionan como esta tabla de aquí
recordemos que tenemos tres grados de
libertad tenemos cuatro categorías
y restamos 1 y nos da 3 el valor de la
cuadrada es 6 por lo que esto de aquí
nos dice que la probabilidad de obtener
un valor igual o mayor que 6.25 para la
gi cuadrada es del 10% si vemos de nuevo
esta imagen sabemos que la probabilidad
de tener 6.25 o más cuando tenemos 3
grados de libertad esto de aquí es el
10% y si esto es 10% entonces la
probabilidad de tener un valor de la
cuadrada mayor o igual que 6 va a ser
mayor al 10% también podemos ver esto
como el valor p así que para nuestra
probabilidad suponiendo que la hipótesis
nula es verdadera si es mayor al 10%
entonces definitivamente es mayor que
nuestro nivel de significancia debido a
esto no podemos rechazar la hipótesis
nula este es un ejemplo de que aunque
nuestra muestra resulte tener más de es
la probabilidad de tener un resultado
tan extremo como lo que vimos va a ser
un poco mayor al 10% nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo